dany langue merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors cette baisse de
20 milliards d'euros des impôts de
production sur deux ans elle était
attendue par les entreprises à mai sera
t-elle selon-vous suffisante pour
relancer l'économie alors
personnellement je pense que déjà on
peut pas dire grand chose à ce stade
parce qu'on nous annonce 20 milliards de
baisses d impôts sur la production mais
on ne nous dit pas de quels impôts il
s'agit et on part une fois de plus du
postulat que le problème est un problème
d'offre donc d'habitude quand on nous
parle d'investissements de
relocalisation de la part de ce
gouvernement on met en cause deux choses
le coût du travail
ou alors le niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires
or ce ne sont pas les principaux
déterminants de l'investissement ou de
la localisation des entreprises donc une
fois de plus ce gouvernement s'en faire
et s'enferme dans un logiciel libéral
est par ailleurs comme il ne nous dit
pas comment est ce qu'ils comptent faire
baisser ses impôts sur la production
c'est très difficile évidemment s'il
s'agirait par exemple interruption
quelles seraient les solutions par
exemple écouter pour le principal
déterminant de la localisation d'une
entreprise ça n'est pas seulement la
fiscalité relocaliser les entreprises ça
passe aussi par du volontarisme
politique pas rendre les circuits
économiques plus court ça passe par la
promotion du made in france
ce que ne fait pas ce gouvernement et je
n'ai pas entendu dans la bouche de
monsieur le maire ni de monsieur castex
le mot de politique industrielle ça
demanderait une véritable politique
industrielle
impulsée par l'état centré sur un
certain nombre de secteurs prioritaires
là où une baisse des impôts qu en
faisant comme si les impôts était le
seul motif de localisation sur le
territoire alors qu'il y en a beaucoup
d'autres
donc je suis assez dubitatif évidemment
il faudrait revoir le barème de l'impôt
sur les sociétés et faire en particulier
en sorte que plus l'entreprise est
grosse plus elle paye d'impôts sur les
sociétés alors qu'aujourd'hui cet impôt
sur les sociétés dégressif plus
no - vous payer ça ce serait une mesure
positive est intéressante mais je n'ai
pas entendu parler de ce genre de choses
alors jean castex a néanmoins annoncé 40
milliards d'euros pour l'industrie ce
n'est pas suffisant selon vous dans une
véritable politique industrielle ça ne
passe ça passe évidemment par des sommes
et ensuite ça passe par un ciblage et
parfaire une liste des industries qui
sont prioritaires et ça passe aussi par
une certaine protection des industries
en question les industries qui se sont
développées ou qui ont pu se relocaliser
où se redévelopper partout s'est passé
par des protections douanières est à
richert je n'ai pas entendu ça de la
part du gouvernement et pour cause des
traités de libre-échange dans lesquelles
nous sommes l'interdisent alors en tout
cas il aura fallu attendre cette crise
sanitaire sans précédent pour favoriser
ou en tant qu à entendre favoriser la
relocalisation de l'emploi en france
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard est-ce
que c'est symbolique
quel est votre regard non c'est pas trop
tard il fallait s'y prendre a évidemment
beaucoup plus tôt il ne fallait pas
accepté de vendre nos grands industrie
comme l'ont fait les gouvernements
successifs devant de grandes industries
à des investisseurs étrangers et il
fallait certainement pas permettre à nos
grands good à les localiser leurs
filiales à l'étranger pour des raisons
fiscales et pour des raisons de soi
disant coût du travail
il aurait fallu une politique
industrielle beaucoup plus volontariste
et beaucoup plus
en soutien aux industries françaises
nous avons encore en france un certain
nombre d'industries remarquable eh bien
ces industries là il faut les soutenir
et pas seulement par des baisses
d'impôts il faut les soutenir aussi en
organisant des filières qu'ils soient
beaucoup plus localisées en permettant à
ces entreprises d'avoir une demande
parce que ce gouvernement est obsédé par
le côté l'offre mais on va être dans les
mois à venir avec l'augmentation du
chômage aux marcheurs face à des
problèmes de demande donc il faudra il
faudrait aussi réfléchir à ses
dimensions là et puis ce qui est
totalement absent aussi de cette
réflexion sur la relocalisation des
industries en tout cas j'ai pas entendre
du gouvernement en parler c'est la
dimension écologique
il faudrait absolument relocaliser notre
industrie alimentaire pour faire enfin
de l'agriculture de qualité et proximité
alors en tout cas enveloppe de 100
milliards d'euros à 1 consacrés à ce
plan de relance
toujours cette même question il vient
d'où cet argent ça existe l'argent
magique ou pas alors je ne dirais pas
que l'argent l'argent magique existe
mais on se retrouve aujourd'hui dans une
situation où l'état peut emprunter à des
taux quasiment nulle sur les marchés
financiers dont qu'on m'emprunte
gratuitement la banque centrale a pris
en pension un certain nombre de ces
têtes donc temps que la banque centrale
européenne garde c'est d'être dans son
bilan il n'est pas nécessaire de les
rembourser
donc effectivement il ya des marges de
manoeuvre et non seulement il ya des
marges de manoeuvre mais on devrait
utiliser ses marges de manoeuvre pour la
priorité absolue qui devrait être la
transition écologique et la
revalorisation des secteurs prioritaires
et on a vu pendant cette crise du plô
vite justement quelles sont les
véritables de secteurs pire prioritaire
à commencer par l'hôpital des services
publics les services de proximité qui
sont beaucoup plus importants que les
industries délocalisées de gadgets qui
sont aujourd'hui produits en chine
merci beaucoup dany lang d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et membre des
économistes atterrés